if you want to hear about the secret
activity Jill tuck participated in
behind the scenes and the meaning behind
it and stick around to the end of this
video
[Music]
jigsaw the most notorious antihero of
the Saw franchise was driven to commit
his crimes based on what he saw as in
Justices in his past perhaps the one
person who was most closely tied to the
events that inspired his actions was his
then wife Jill tuck Kramer and in
today's lesson we are discussing why you
should never marry an older man for his
money because he might turn out to be a
serial killer no we're gonna be
analyzing the character of Jill tuck and
to do so we've got to take it back to
the first mention of jigsaws girl Jill
tuck Kramer was a doctor who sought to
help drug addicts by running a Recovery
Center called homeward bound clinic
whose motto cherish your life was
adopted from a phrase created by Jill's
husband John Kramer it's likely that the
two were drawn to each other because of
their mutual interest in helping people
improve their lives but they would
ultimately find differing methods of
going about it
but John loved his wife so he took her
on picnics and recorded her on a video
camera in the park because I guess
that's what you do when you're in love
in 1995 Jill becomes pregnant with their
first child John started to have doubts
about the effectiveness of the
treatments his wife was administering to
the drug addicts at home or on clinic as
he was waiting for her to get done
working one evening he witnessed a fight
break out when one of the patients a man
named Cecil Adams gets fed up with how
long he's been standing by in the
waiting room actual footage of me trying
to get on the Haggard ride Jill tries to
stop the brawl but John has to step in
when Cecil looks like he's about to plot
a knife
John is able to get him to calm down and
put it away as the due date of the baby
gets closer John calls Jill into his
workshop and shows her a series of gifts
that he's been working on including a
clock built with a 300 year old
mechanism meant to be a symbolic of
their long lasting relationship a crib
for the incoming baby and a cute version
of Billy the puppet in the form of a
children's toy which I'm not sure why
this hasn't become a merchandising
phenomenon Lionsgate but I digress the
entire pregnancy was perfectly planned
by John from the baby's birth and the
Chinese year of the pig - the name
Gideon which is also the name of the
first building that John ever owned the
gideon meat-packing plans no I wouldn't
personally made my kid after a meat
packer
implants but the name may have been
drawn from the Hebrew name katana which
means hero or judge both of which john
saw himself as one day during an
ultrasound john pulls out the old
camcorder and they make a home video for
giddy why does that come off as
incredibly creepy all right because it's
the same guy who made a videotapes for
all the people he tortured and murdered
the event that would set all of that in
motion would soon come during another
evening at the homeward bound clinic
Jill who is now seven months pregnant
was finishing up and about to go home
when Cecil appears and claims that he
forgot his jacket inside when she goes
to give it to him he forces his way in
holds dread nice points so he can steal
more medications to relieve his fix
in doing so he slams the door into her
pregnant belly John knows something is
wrong when he sees Cecil fleeing the
building and goes in to find his wife
collapsed on the floor he rushes her to
a hospital but the baby is unable to be
saved which would put a huge strain on
their relationship the reason that this
tore them apart is not just related to
the emotional trauma but also their
ideals which were drifting apart
Jill believed that her treatment which
included medication and therapy was the
best solution but John was becoming
convinced that this was not enough all I
wanted to do was help
especially after seeing Jill's treatment
was ineffective in some patients such as
Cecil Adams and another woman named
Amanda young meanwhile Jill was left
alone to cope with the loss while John
fell into a deep depression and withdrew
himself from the marriage you blame me
in what may have been a last-ditch
effort by Jill to pull John out of his
depression she shows up at his workshop
with his lawyer heart blanked he tries
to convince John to come back and return
to his work which involved helping
families in need
um if you're homeless just buy a house
john is unwilling to cooperate he
forfeits his shares of the company to
Jill who ended up shutting down the
Guinea and meatpacking plant for unknown
reasons
at some point they got divorced and
between that and the fact that Seinfeld
was ending she dropped the Kramer
hyphenation off of her last name and
went back to just being Jill tuck
sometime around then the Jill's family
abandons a pig farm that they owned in
the countryside due to an outbreak of
odd jetskis disease after dealing with
that
Jill hears that her ex-husband had
attempted suicide so being the forgiving
caregiver that she is she seeks him out
to try to talk to him when she goes into
the workshop she finds reconnaissance
photos of Cecil perhaps confirming her
suspicions that John had something to do
with his death when she found John she
claimed that he was now a different
person seeing the horrors of what his
new work consisted of she discovers the
truth that John had turned Cecil into
the first victim of his so-called
rehabilitation Jill doesn't approve of
his methods causing the go ballistic and
destroy the clock that he'd once made
for her the symbol of their long-lasting
connection was now gone
[Music]
they don't come back we do it for
yourself if you can't do it for me
I lost two the two would separate for
several years after that until John came
back to the clinic to confront his ex on
her methods one more time
[Music]
after becoming jigsaw John would spend a
good amount of his time trying to
rehabilitate the ex-patients of the
homeward bound clinic the most notable
of which was Amanda young after John
believed that she was clean following
his tests of her in 2004 he brought her
back to homeward bound as proof to jail
that his rehabilitation methods weren't
working Jill had previously dropped
Amanda from her list of patients
thinking that she was a lost cause
so she was shocked to see that her
ex-husband was able to turn Amanda into
an ex-addict at least it appeared that
way this encounter did not immediately
change Jill's mind about John's work but
rather would become something that she
would look back on in a few years while
contemplating whether or not to help
carry out his legacy the couple would
have one more meeting that we know of in
April of 2006 not long before the main
events of saw 3 & 4 John and his
followers were busy setting up the final
two games of jigsaws life one of which
involves him testing a doctor and her
husband at gideon meat-packing plant
which sat abandoned ever since Jill shut
it down she was still the owner of the
building now and turns up one day to beg
John to put an end to his work as jigsaw
he ignores her request and instead
promises her a way out when everything
is over with
Rohit's
[Music]
which is 4
[Music]
all the times right
[Music]
that would be their final encounter in
person shortly before John's death the
police investigate Jill is a suspected
accomplice after discovering that she
was in possession of the Billy doll and
tricycle used in the videos left to many
of jigsaws victims the investigation
wrecks havoc on her life she ends up
being interrogated for according to her
hundreds of hours she also claims many
things were taken from her home for the
investigation on April 28th jigsaw is
running two games one of which is a test
for officer Daniel Ray the FBI agent
Strahm and Perez are following him and
they arrived at his home were the first
phase of the test took place the walls
are covered in photos of jigsaws victims
but there's one wildcard Jill tuck can
also be seen in the photos and I love
how John just took the time to get these
candid photos of his ex-wife out and
about in town I mean I know they got
divorced but he seriously didn't have
one photo I mean he could print it out
her myspace picture or something I mean
kind of weird to be secretly taking
photos of your ex who's way younger than
you anyway this leads straumann frezz to
confront her at her work and bring her
in for even more questioning this time
instead of just asking about John they
were also asking about her at the end of
the games draws near Strom gets more
desperate for the answers that have
eluded him he threatens to pin the
charges on her and also physically pins
her to the wall to intimidate her
Jill doesn't have much to tell but she
does tell him about her divorce this
eventually leads Strom to ask about the
location of gideon meat-packing plant
John's first building where the two
games were taking place she does not
realize that she's sending Strom into a
trap of his own which is facilitated by
jigsaws actual accomplice detective
Markoff Chuck and Hoffman would
establish sort of a rivalry that ramped
up after John's death in the
twenty-eighth Hoffman wanted dill out of
the picture so that he could have
complete control over jigsaws legacy and
make judgments on his own while Jill was
growing a disdain for Hoffman because he
was starting to act against John's final
wishes by taking over the games that
John didn't have time to carry out in
life for selfish reasons in order to
increase his power despite the fact that
they couldn't make their marriage work
Jill still had enough respect for John
to want to see that his final requests
are carried out properly and Hoffman was
getting in the way of that not long
after news of John Kramer's death and
identity as jigsaw went public and she
finds herself surrounded by news
articles claiming to know and understand
both sides of John Kramer which must
have been surreal because the only one
that truly knew both sides of him was
her the media also speculated on her
involvement even though she had not
actually been involved up to that point
she noticed she was being followed and
that didn't surprise her at first
because of the initial wave of media
attention
soon grew paranoid that someone was
stalking her she meets with John's
executive command responsible for paying
out John's will who shows her a VHS
containing one final message from her
late ex-husband well that's it if you're
watching this Jill I'm long gone from
this world you are my art you always
have been you always things not to say
to your ex for five hundred it's
important to note John's clothing and
hair style during this tape which tells
us that it was recorded just before the
main event since all three the game that
potentially could have ended with John
being killed or possibly imprisoned for
the remainder of his life even though
they were not speaking at the time John
still has Jill's best interests at the
top of his mind even as he's busy making
preparations for the most complex and
dangerous game he's ever held he goes on
to tell her that he blames himself for
what happened to Gideon at homeward
bound clinic and that he encouraged her
work at the time even when he sense
danger was on the horizon this is a bit
different than his stance
immediately after the miscarriage where
he was upset that she could not
understand how the flaws in her
treatment methods led to this had John
blame himself from the beginning I think
it's entirely possible that Jo would
have reacted more receptively and
perhaps they would not have gotten
divorced and things may have gone much
differently he leaves her a box and
tells her she'll know what to do with
the contents that's when she remembers
her final encounter with God and uses
the key he gave her which she's kept on
her this entire time perhaps a sign that
she's still kind of had a place in her
heart for John even after the divorce
and even after learning that he'd become
a serial killer and I think this small
amount of love that she had left for him
starting to influence her decisions
going forward she decides not to take
the contents out of the box in front of
this guy though and I don't blame her I
mean look at those eyes
[Music]
the box contains six numbered envelopes
one labeled parcel and a number of
related materials and instructions
including one of jigsaws most iconic
traps a Jill would wisely wait until she
knew she was alone before opening them
after receiving the box from John Jill
still could not shake the feeling that
someone was stalking her and goes to the
FBI headquarters to inform the head of
the investigation but for some reason he
just wouldn't stop asking her pictures
of spider-man nah that's not him she
tells him that she believes that agent
Strahm the man who interrogated her is
responsible she later opens the
envelopes and finds that they contain
profiles I'm six more victims who were
to be tested in upcoming games the first
five are players in the trial of William
Houston an insurance mogul who once
rejected John's request recovery that's
the main game in sauce settings the
sixth envelope contains a profile on
detective Hoffman who has now become the
successor to jigsaw Hoffman thinks that
he and Jill are the only ones left to
carry out the rest of John's work but
jill has been given a bit more
information than him which again is an
important illustration of where John's
trust really lies Jill knows that there
is one other disciple who's been working
behind the scenes for a long time now
and decides to keep this information to
herself because she senses that John did
not fully trust Hoffman eventually
Hoffman shows up at the clinic and
demands she forfeit the envelopes to him
so that he can be the one to run the
next game he wants to work alone from
now on so he can get away with as much
foul play as he wants she only hands
over envelopes one through five
completely hiding the existence of a
sixth five later Jill receives a visit
from a reporter named Pamela Jenkins who
delivers a note found at gideon
meat-packing plan to the main locations
from saw 3 where john was killed the
note reads Amanda you were with Cecil
the night John lost Gideon you killed
their child you know it and I know it so
do exactly as I say kill lynn denlon or
I will tell John what you did now this
gets a little bit confusing but here's
why it's a big deal for Jill for some
time she's been thinking back on her
conversation with John and Amanda that
was the first time that Jill started to
maybe believe that John's method of
helping people using the traps and games
was superior but when Amanda went off
the rails and failed her final test by
killing one denlon
ventolin ultimately ended up leading to
John's death Jill lost faith in his
methods but this note if genuine proves
that Amanda was blackmailed
so maybe she really was rehabilitated
and only killed lynn denlon to protect
her secret about being with cecil if
this note is indeed from hoffman then
that also proves that he's broken the
rules in order to take a man two outs
and become the only disciple of jigsaw
and if that is the case he's dangerous
and needs to be stopped
Jill knows that she probably can't
defeat Hoffman on her own so she plays
her trump card and pays a visit to the
disciple that she knows about but
Hoffman does not jigsaws greatest asset
dr. Lauren scored the winner of the
bathroom game two years ago in 2004 jill
goes to the hospital that Gordon now
works at and delivers the parcel into
the slot on his door it contains a tape
left behind by John telling Gordon to
act immediately if anything should
happen to jail with the peace of mind
that she'll at least be avenged as she
fails
Jill gathers the last of the materials
that John had left her in his will and
shows up to the location of the next
game to administer Hoffman's final test
she manages to subdue him by running an
electric current through the back of his
chair and leaving the note that he had
once used to blackmail Amanda on the
desk once Hoffman read the note and
realized that somebody else knew his
secret she activated the electricity to
incapacitate him strapped into the chair
and brought out the final item left to
her in the box from John's will the
reverse bear trap which was famously
used a test Amanda back in 2004 Jill was
finally about to carry out John's final
wish but because she wasn't there with
him during the final years of his life
she never got to hear this important
piece of advice you're assuming this is
gonna play out the way you want it
Oh Jill did not anticipate the
possibility of Hoffman escaping the trap
and when he does she's forced to run for
it and hide out until Hoffman leaves the
building
taking the reverse bear trap with him
both mark Hoffman and Jill tuck go dark
for almost a year and all the while Jill
is haunted by nightmares of Hoffman
capturing her and brutally ending her
life as a revenge for messing up his jaw
still she's able to stay hidden for a
long time until March of 2007 when she
hears about a new jigsaw trap taking
place in public with the knowledge that
Hoffman is active again her paranoia
gets the better of her and she goes to
the police station seeking protection
which is honestly kind of insane because
her husband was responsible for the
death of like five of their cops and
let's not forget the creation of Hoffman
who's like the biggest psycho ever so a
pretty ballsy of Jill to trust the cops
at this point but apparently she's got a
good feeling about this guy Matt Gibson
from internal affairs
she tells him that Hoffman is jigsaws
successor and secret accomplice and
offers what she knows in exchange for
protection and immunity he puts her in a
safe house but after Hoffman
demonstrates that he knows that she's
there this was sent here addressed to
Jill Hoffman knows our location God
moves her to a high-security holding
cell for her protection
none of these precautions however are
enough to stop Hoffman from getting
there
he holds the body of an assistant to the
window in order to get the guards to
open the door and takes them out in
order to bring himself face to face with
Jill talk I'll be looking for you in a
last-ditch effort she stabs him in the
neck and runs to hide in the evidence
room he still finds her though and in a
cruel twist of fate straps her to the
very same chair where she had left him
to die less than one year ago unlike
Amanda and Hoffman Jill is not able to
escape from the reverse bear trap and
meets her demise
however her backup plan did work as
Lawrence Gordon was quickly able to
avenge her so she was still able to be a
part of the plan to carry out John's
final wish
even in death I think Jill tuck actually
has one of the best character arcs in
the series when we meet her she's very
convinced that her way of helping people
using medication and traditional therapy
is the only way to help these troubled
people overcome their addiction John's
philosophy is that going through an
immense amount of suffering can help
someone see the light and although John
isn't intentionally putting her through
any suffering she does suffer the loss
of her unborn son and the loss of her
marriage and this eventually leads to
her realization that John's judgments
although oftentimes cruel could be
effective and she ends up playing a key
part and bringing down the series most
evil villain as a result it's kind of
easy to overlook her character arc
because her story is chopped up and
distributed intermittently throughout
size 4 through 7 and rarely becomes the
main focus but hopefully this horror
history gives you a better idea of why
she did what she did behind the scenes
and what her character means for the
franchise so your homework is to let me
know in the comments who I should cover
next on Horror Story and make sure you
check out that playlist on the left for
more episodes including other saw
characters remember to subscribe to
seize these worlds for new Horrors every
week to bring my death the battle for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive